[Vsauce]
Hey, Vsauce, Michael here,
and you guys
are my family.
Scientifically speaking,
geneticists tell us
that every single person on earth
is, at the least,
50th cousins
with everybody else on earth.
It kind of has to be that way.
Think of it like this—
you have two biological parents
and four biological grandparents,
and eight biological great-grandparents.
It keeps doubling.
Well, if you follow your family tree
all the way back
to the time of the ancient Romans,
64 generations ago,
that tree would need
one quintillion separate individuals,
which is a number
that is larger
than the number of humans
who have ever existed. Ever.
So what does that mean?
Well, I think Bill Bryson put it best
when he said,
"You couldn't be here
without a little incest—
actually, quite a lot of incest."
Nothing ridiculous, mind you,
but if you go far enough back
in your family tree,
you're going to find that quite frequently,
people who were distantly related
had kids.
In fact, if you are currently dating
or married to somebody
who is from your own country
and is of your own ethnicity,
there's a one in five chance
that the two of you share
a common family member
fewer than 10 generations ago.
Furthermore, because our society
is becoming more and more mobile,
our most recent common ancestor
is becoming more recent.
Mathematical models are now showing us
that for everybody,
every human on earth right now,
our most recent common ancestor
probably lived
only 2,000 to 4,000 years ago.
A recent study—it's a great one,
you should read it—
found that there was
a person alive
as early as 300 B.C.
who is related
to every single person alive
on Earth today.
Their study also found
that that person most likely lived
in Taiwan
near a busy port city,
so their descendants could quickly spread
around the world.
Now, all that said, you only receive half
of your genetic information
from your mother
and half from your father,
and as you go up your tree,
it's quite possible
that distant, distant ancestors
had literally no contribution
to your genome.
So who are you?
I've said this before,
but because bacteria
are so much smaller
than the average human body cell,
your body contains
more bacteria
than it contains its own cells.
And forget about trying to remember
every individual cell and bacteria in your body.
They're constantly dying
and being replaced.
Even cells like brain cells,
which seem to live
for a very long time,
still take in new nutrients
and expel waste, meaning
that within about every five years,
every single atom
that used to make up your body
has been exchanged.
Do you remember
what you were like five years ago?
Well, the atoms that make up your body,
they sure don't.
This is a little existentially scary,
but it leads to a very good question.
How many atoms are inside my body
to begin with?
How much is a billion atoms?
Well, here's one way
to think about this.
If you were to count
one number greater every second,
it would take you 12 days
to count to a million,
and if you wanted to count
to a billion,
that would take you 32 years.
So a billion
is a very large number,
but not when it comes to atoms.
Atoms are so inconceivably small
that even if you had
a billion, say, sodium atoms,
their entire weight
would only be
38 femtograms.
Each individual cell
in your body,
too small
to be even seen by the eye,
contains 100 times more atoms
than there are stars
in the Milky Way galaxy.
Multiply that by the number of cells
that make up
what we call ourselves,
and each human body
contains more atoms
than there are stars
in the known universe.
Numbers that large lead
to some pretty mind-blowing truths,
for instance, this one mentioned
by Bill Bryson—
because our bodies contain
so many atoms,
and because we
so vigorously recycle them,
statistically speaking,
about one billion of the atoms
inside your body
used to belong to Shakespeare.
A billion of your atoms
used to belong to Beethoven.
A billion of the atoms
in your body
right now,
as you sit and watch this,
used to be inside the body
of Buddha.
You could also think of it this way—
a thousand years from now,
when humans first land
on a planet
outside of our solar system,
that first person
to step onto the surface
of the alien planet—
their body will contain
a billion atoms
that are in you
right now.
And as always,
thanks for watching.
[Vsauce]